tila hello hi lady we have so much to
talk about
first let's get into the clubhouse
beverly hills
congratulations your friday thank you
you are the first black woman to be a
part of this house
and you have a lot of young girls who
follow you what do you want them to take
away from you making this move
um i want my viewers and my fans to take
away
the fact that black is beautiful black
is powerful
i never want any of my viewers to feel
like they're in a box oh i'm black i
can't do this oh i'm
i'm a black girl i'm a black guy and you
know or i'm a person of color and i
can't be in this group where i can't
hang out with this person because
you know i just should be over here like
absolutely not i
think of myself as a variety pack i love
just
sprinkling myself in different
situations and doing many different
things and
i feel like as a black woman being in a
house filled with just
a lot of white people um it's kind of
cool to
show other black viewers that hey you
can do it you can do anything you
you want to do it doesn't matter what
race you are and don't ever feel like
oh because i'm black i have to put
myself in a box or i have to put myself
in a category because there's absolutely
nothing that
we can't do like sky's the limit and i
just want my viewers to know that
right well you had a lot of long time
like you're a long time youtube fans
they felt a certain type of way about it
some of them
why was this the best move for you
because they've watched you you know
since you were
an actress on tv and they followed you
for so long
but some of them are you know just not
necessarily confused but just questioned
why you decided that the clubhouse
beverly hills was for you
why is that i think they were confused
because they're like you already have
followers like why are you putting
yourself in a house and
i didn't join this house to become
relevant like i've been online for
years and i still managed to be quite
relevant to be honest because i've been
doing it for so long a lot of people
would have just fallen off
um but i did it because i just wanted
change i
you know i've always lived with my
parents i've i lived really far away
from
beverly hills but i would always drive
an hour away to be at melrose
and beverly hills and when the
opportunity came i was just like why not
i've been wanting a little bit of change
and
um i just want to surround myself with a
lot of people that are super creative
and just constantly want to pop out
content because during quarantine i mean
i felt a little stuck i mean it's hard
to be motivated when you're just like
locked inside your house you know and
you really have nothing to do
whereas when you live with a bunch of
people that are constantly creating i
just feel like
you get inspired by each other and
everybody just bounces off each other's
with
different ideas whether that's for tick
tock whether that's for instagram or
youtube and i just feel like it was just
the right atmosphere
for me well i did like a deep dive on
your youtube channel and as you say
you've been doing this for years
but on top of doing it for years you're
also so raw
and vulnerable you know you give a lot
of yourself to your fans
does that ever get overwhelming for you
do you ever have a moment where you're
like
i don't know if i want to do this
anymore um definitely
uh i think for a long time now i've kind
of i've always been an all-or-nothing
type of person that goes for
relationships friendships
my work everything like in every genre
i've always been
all or nothing so i'm starting to really
learn this year to kind of pull back on
that
it is very difficult for me though
because i just love giving my all and i
love being
100 authentic which i still will be but
i feel like i should take everything
with a grain of salt and know that
everything i put out there
people are gonna have opinions no matter
what and um
i feel like it's been a trend to hate on
me since like 2016. it's
honestly gotten really old at this point
like you can
i've been called every name in the book
i can tell i can sit down and say how
much i love being a black woman but i'll
still get comments
from actually black girls saying that
but you want to be white so bad and i
would never
like i love being black i love my family
i love the color that i'm in i love
just everything about being black it's
literally beautiful when you get off the
screen what do you tell yourself or
do you have friends around you or your
mom who gives you advice on how to deal
with those haters because
it sounds like you have tough skin but
nobody has
when it comes to youtube it can be like
i think a lot of people just look at my
lifestyle they look at who i'm
surrounded with and they're like
oh tila has it all like she has money
she's a pretty girl she's skinny like
she'll get over it i'm just gonna
literally like send her death threats
and tell her that
like her body is plastic and blah blah
like it doesn't matter she has money and
she is like
she's successful it doesn't matter
people don't realize that it doesn't
matter how successful you are how much
money you have or what you're surrounded
by you're still a human being with
feelings
but i feel like because of followers and
success people kind of put you in a
robot category
and they forget that you're actually a
human being like and you have feelings
and you have
days that are ups and you know days that
are down but i feel like what really
keeps me grounded is the fact that i
have an amazing
family my family has been supporting me
literally since i wanted to be an
actress at six years old
they've always just said like you can do
whatever you
put your mind to as long as you work
hard and if you want something like go
out and get it like my parents were
always like
don't ever like put 10 into something
like just give it your all
and really go for it and i started
acting when i was 6 years old
because my older sister started doing it
before me and i think because
i started out as an as a traditional
actress that gave me such tough skin i
mean i started out as six years old
getting rejected you know a casting call
saying oh yeah no she's adorable but
like she doesn't fit the right part so
i've
kind of always been surrounded by people
telling me no and people
judging me so then when social media
came along
obviously it's a lot harsher than just
saying oh you're not right for this role
but it's still the same thing of being
rejected so i've dealt with rejection
pretty much all my life and so i feel
like that's actually helped me a lot it
wasn't a culture shock to get hate or
to feel like somebody doesn't think i'm
their cup of tea because i've dealt with
it so much
as an actress i like your take on that
too because i mean that makes sense how
you're still
able to be in this arena with 100
percent
i want to talk about your boob job
you've put
your followers through the entire
process
now in a world where there are so many
people that have something to say about
your body
why did you feel like you needed to show
your fans step by step this process
because now we also live in a world too
where body positivity is just promoted
at a you know an entirely different
level and you sat there and said
i love myself but i want to change
something so why was that important for
you
um so during corinthian like when it was
like quarantined quarantine where i was
on lockdown lockdown
um i this is gonna sound so crazy but i
had a dream
that i got a boob job and i woke up
thinking that i had gotten the boob job
and i woke up
so happy and then i kind of went down a
rabbit hole of watching all these
youtube videos
of these young girls getting boob jobs
and the process of it i just like kept
watching every single day and i realized
i didn't find that many youtube videos
that were super
raw and honest about the whole process
it was kind of just like a q a after the
boobs were done
and just kind of jumbled up i i rarely
saw
youtube videos of like the surgery the
pre-op
everything and i was like you know what
i could be that to somebody that
wants this or is curious about this and
another thing is is
i never want to be that person that
lies about what i've got done um you
know when i was
14 years old and i started youtube i was
embarrassed about having a weave i was
embarrassed and i thought people would
think i was bald so i didn't really want
to talk about
my hair so i'd be like oh like they're
just extensions or whatever
and now obviously yeah this is the weave
obviously welcome
to hollywood but it's the same principle
of i just don't want to hide things it
is what it is it doesn't matter
i talk about my eyelash extensions i
talk about my weave why wouldn't i talk
about a boob job you know obviously
that's a little more extreme
but um when i told my mom i wanted a
boob job i was so nervous to tell her i
didn't want her to think that like
la changed me or that i wanted to be
something that i wasn't
um but she was so supportive of
everything and she's like absolutely
you're 23 years old like this is your
body
i'm fully i fully support you and um we
found an amazing doctor dr govami
and then i documented the entire process
start to finish
and obviously when i first got them done
i don't know if a lot of people know
this but
when you first get implants they're like
very very high up like
literally all the way up here they don't
move you know they need to settle in
with your body it takes like
it takes six months for them to like
fully drop but it takes like
two to three months for them to like
start moving and stuff so obviously
because i documented the whole process
people were not getting giving me hate
they actually were very
surprised and i feel like i got a lot of
respect because people were like wow
she's so honest she's not hiding this at
all like
wow didn't see this coming but then you
know
as time went on i wanted to like show
how they were looking and i got a lot of
hate because they're like oh my god
you're so plastic they look terrible
blah blah blah
and that's just like really messed up
and not true i went to the best doctor
there is like the number one plastic
surgeon
in beverly hills and if people did their
research they'd realized that when i
showed my boobs they were two weeks old
they're gonna be up here they're not
gonna move i just got them done
so you know take everything with a grain
of salt of course everyone's gonna have
something to say
first i'm too flat chested now i'm
plastic you know it's just like whatever
but at the end of the day i'm really
happy that i was honest
about it and i don't regret my decision
at all like i love my boobs i'm able to
wear
shirts that i was never able to wear
ever
and i just feel a lot more confident in
my body i feel like more like a woman
because
i always get comments like oh my god you
look like you're 14 like you you look
15 14. um you know and i feel i still
look super young but i feel a lot more
older and mature and
it definitely helped my confidence yeah
and do you remind yourself like i did
this for me
at the end of the day a hundred percent
there was no other reason for me to do
it
besides like you know i have so many
amazing dresses and i'm like oh my god i
have to wear all these victoria's secret
bras but then i never
like showing the bra cause i feel like
that's kind of inappropriate you know in
your bra shows and it's like oh
i don't want to get a photo with like my
bra showing you know so it was really
annoying wearing all these
victoria secret push-up bras that would
show in photos and i'm just like oh i
hate this
no i don't need to and it's really nice
i love it